I call well I drank one it's um it's
called trap juice trap sauce I mean we
have we have this friend that makes
[ __ ] weed infused vodka for and he
makes it for st. Patty's Day that sounds
a [ __ ] so it's all green and it's
called trap sauce and he brings it over
in in like a like a handle like he'll
make a handle of it so it's like a
handle of Tito's that he brings over and
it's lime green it looks like toxic
waste it was called trap sauce but it's
like if people like I've seen people
drink that and it just [ __ ] him up how
does everyone not vomiting at the party
I mean I don't even know how you did
yeah like I would have a half a shot of
that now just have like vertigo and just
you ever be drunk in high at the same
time no never been the worst feeling I
in the entire will avoid that to the tee
yeah it's just cease you've really never
never tried it
mm-hmm mmm never take a little no no no
you're drunk I can be as drunk as can be
in someone gonna be like dude you want
to smoke this and the dad and me comes
out no that's very irresponsible
crossing the two you're gonna want to
come back to me in two hours I'll do it
in two hours you see the dad segment of
my brain is just totally he's just
locked on existing is I have one drink
it's like yeah sure yeah that's cool
yeah scale this yell if dived wire fence
and trap sauce that sounds delicious
bring it over yeah give me some yeah
[ __ ] chug that [ __ ] sprinkle that
right on top of ketamine yeah beer bong
some traps awesome yeah yeah sure
where's my coffee there we go
no boy it's tough for me to drink that
thing though first of all that's like a
eight meals and one smoothie take them
all mm-hmm it's tough for me to drink
that though because I went ham last
night on the on the meal you know mm you
know Thanksgivings is s special we had a
friendsgiving last night and another
white thing dude and I was thinking
while we were doing it I was like this I
just we just keep outdoing ourselves for
how [ __ ]
it's not like you want to know what the
Thema did you see my Instagram story do
you went out with a theme of last night
was ready to talk about yeah yeah would
you call it denim what denims giving
denims giving yeah so it's right now
we're all like let's do this friends
giving my buddy planned it and we were
all super stoked for it we all had our
own dishes that we were making and
whatnot and then my friend was like I
want to I want to make it a theme like I
want to make it fun and so he's like I
was thinking denim and everyone was like
dude that's a great thing definitely go
with that and so he texted out he's like
all right it's all denim that's the
theme and we all got really really into
it everyone yeah nobody even responded
to that message everyone which is like
that's [ __ ] dope and took it upon
themselves to like really really out do
it like the all the the guys who hosted
it all three of them had the same denim
sure that they went out and bought at
Ross Wow the day before Wow it was a
moment where during the dinner I was
just I was looking at there's a picture
actually from the dinner and was like
god I hope never nobody ever sees this
picture outside of the people that were
there 10 white people and all denim just
sounds like something got oppressed I
don't know what or something offensive
happened or that or it says it's
probably it probably just looks like a
bad Abercrombie spread I'm saying from
the eighties yeah like like time you
were the hottest they could get and then
they look back in ten years they're like
oh god talent really come a long way but
were we thinking
talent and fashion talent in fashion I
hope this just never comes back and so
it was it was it was it was funny no I'm
sure it was funny yeah but it's just
like yeah I don't know I know it was a
joke though cuz if it was done um you
know like that I'm sure there are I'm
sure there's a denims giving somewhere
that is not ironic come over at home
okay yeah that sounds really awesome
probably late yeah it's in the Arts
District yes someone's aloft yep
definitely West Hollywood there's a
weather's giving
they eat a bomb they roast and cook a
bomb for 16 hours cocaine I think when
we talk about eating bomb sets that's
when we kind of got to reevaluate where
we're going with this bit yes but it was
like I [ __ ] we what we all just
couldn't move yeah that's another thing
it's like you just feel after doing that
it's like why don't we chat all just
eating ourselves to death right now like
this just seems it seems wrong it's the
time where you really do sit back and
think there are hungry people and other
parts of the world I'm heating myself to
pain it's like sport it's like a sport
to us in America on Thanksgiving to eat
to the point of like just being super
uncomfortable yeah like I ate to the
point where was hard to breathe wow I've
never had that what you've done that no
does Thanksgiving not to breath you just
made me think real quick do you think if
people saw competition hotdog eating in
places where food was scarce did they
just must roll over just like you [ __ ]
these people they're [ __ ] food is not
a game just to puke it all up and to say
ah man maybe I'll eat them faster next
year that's that's I mean that's what it
was we're just sitting there we're like
I can't even eat dessert Wow good part
of the meal because I because I and
there's still tons of leftovers it's
just like you're gonna eat them all yeah
yeah [ __ ] yeah I am I made it I made a
real bomb I gotta tell you what the best
part of the meal was I think the best
part was Marcus's mac and cheese really
that kid [ __ ] murdered him and Claire
they made mac and cheese and they made
deviled eggs which I went apeshit about
this on my podcast someone was like yeah
I've never heard someone go crazy about
deviled eggs so what you just did yeah
they're like my favorite things the
entire world are you serious yeah a
deviled egg
yep if someone was like eat this deviled
egg or I'll kill your whole family
kill my family I [ __ ] hate deviled
eggs how could you hate deviled eggs
they're covered in vinegar they're just
disgust oh so good dude there was a
there was a point last night where I I
took like a bit of stuffing and a bit of
like sweet potatoes and a bit of Turkey
and I dipped it in the deviled egg
without like just got the innards of it
and had that as a superbike oh my god I
go I go ape I'm a I'm a salmon literally
of savage when it comes to this [ __ ]
[ __ ] I was eating with my hands eating
base to plate all over my denim eating a
deviled egg and denim has got to be
[Music]
illegal somewhere I hate deviled eggs
bro never
[Music]
I got some clown
these are got some fun
[Music]